i find it very fascinating that
spider-man is gonna be in venom three
and not the other way around is it gonna
be venom three that features spider-man
yeah how would venom be the villain in
that movie did spider-man be the villain
in that movie because you're only in
eddie brock's perspective would you have
it like be you know like hate whoever
you're gonna be watching both their
perspectives here you know that would be
cool yeah or it's gonna be godzilla
versus kong where they team up at the
end against a big machine yeah maybe yes
more likely there is one where they had
to fight carnage i find that very
interesting i find that very very
interesting
[Music]
don't worry guys after spider-man comes
out it's gonna be nothing but doctor
strange videos from here on out today
we're going to watch the cosmic war and
spider ward spiderman and venom 3 sony
teases expanded universe let's see
what's going on we got venom to look
forward to and spiderman and the more
and more comes out the more it just
seems like venom and spidey are gonna
finally be uniting on screen together
i'm curious to ask people are trying to
figure out venom's potential
relationship with spider-man down the
road do you think that this incarnation
of venom could ever be a spider-man
villain or would he have to be retooled
like to sort of fit into sort of that
spider-man world or could he fit into a
sinister six
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome to andy circus
which coincidentally could actually end
up being kind of the same universe and
i'm definitely going to talk about that
in this video but the big thing
happening right now is sony is actually
teasing something way bigger than just
venom let there be carnage in fact it
actually does tease that venom and
spider-man are going to be going up
against each other very very soon what i
love so far about this venom marketing
campaign is they're like no spoilers
please don't spoil for anyone who saw it
no spoilers and they're also like we're
expanding the universal expansion get
ready for things in the future to
collide with each other like we're kind
of already teasing what might happen and
we have some reports today that talk
about when exactly we'll see spider-man
go up against venom so let's go ahead
and start off with these new promotions
that sony is doing for venom let there
be carnage because they are quite
different so the first promo that we
noticed was a little bit different
happened a few days ago and it comes
from the sony pictures official twitter
account and here's what they posted in
two weeks the universe is expanding in
venom let there be carnage exclusively
in movie theaters on october 1st now
this is interesting and caught a lot of
people's eyes because if this was a
normal venom let there be carnage movie
the universe wouldn't really be
extending then obviously the reason that
we think the universe is expanding is
because of all of the rumors that have
been going around about spider-man and
venom finally meeting up and the timing
of this tweet which i will go on to talk
about in depth in a bit is lining up
with tom hardy and andy serkis the
director of venom and venom 2 both
talking about how spider-man and venom
will meet so this tweet was a little bit
curious but then they sent out another
tweet not too long after a couple of
days after and this one got even more
intriguing the tweet said there's
something wow
i didn't say that
exclusively in movie theaters october
1st get tickets now they literally said
there's something way bigger happening
but in this post they also posted more
footage of venom let there be carnage
and the way that they did this is rather
interesting as well just take a look at
this brief clip rock we've been waiting
in the darkness for you
on october 1st
the universe
is expanding it's something
why me
we all had secrets you know what secrets
wanted they went out
i mean they're practically telling us
that that's what somebody does
guys the spider-man spider-man
spider-man seems like there's just more
and more indicators that it's for sure
going to be happening pretty soon this
is more clearer than ever tom hardy
seems to be much more outspoken and more
vocal about it than ever before and yeah
the fact that they're calling this a
universe now because they do call it
like the sony spider-man universe it's
either they're going to be teasing
another villain who's supposed to be
coming like we already know we got
morbius craven the hunter is already in
development right now but i think when
you're trying to capitalize on universe
and spider-man no way home coming out i
feel like they're trying to elude like
you're going to want to check in for
this one this one's going to be imported
to check out like you don't want to skip
this one because what don't we already
know for sure spider-man involvement
yeah as they say the universe is
expanding when they say the universe in
this tv spot clip they actually show
detective mulligan reading from the
daily bugle now of course we all know
the daily bugle from spider-man and this
honestly is actually feeling a lot like
sam raimi's spider-man 3 right now where
eddie brock works for the daily bugle
alongside of spider-man well peter
parker to their knowledge but that's
kind of the feeling that i get right now
and if you take a look at that newspaper
it is the same exact daily bugle from
the sam raimi spider-verse like
literally exactly the same what exactly
is sony trying to tell us here because
venom let there be carnage isn't exactly
a big multiverse film yet we have the
daily bugle that exists in another
universe appearing in this film we have
andy serkis the director talking about
how eventually spider-man is going to
meet venom
i'm curious to ask people are trying to
figure out venom's potential
relationship with spider-man down the
road do you think that this incarnation
of venom could ever be a spider-man
villain or would he have to be retooled
like to sort of fit into sort of that
spider-man world or could he fit into a
sinister set
well i mean they're all those questions
are you know ones which we we've not
purposefully not focused on right now i
mean i i
and and i kind of don't want to um give
any sort of fake hope or false
information about things that might be
happening in the future i mean obviously
at some point he's you know those worlds
are going to collide big time they are i
mean if we get if we are so lucky as to
make more venom movies
and tom hardy and andy circus did an
interview together with brandon davis of
comicbook.com where he asked them about
that infamous picture that tom hardy
posted to his instagram and deleted the
one of venom eating spiderman where you
can see his arms and legs hanging out of
venom's mouth he also asked about the
daily bugle and essentially said is
spider-man on your minds for the future
in which tom hardy replied of course
it's on our minds all the time look at
the photo those little spidey legs
hanging out of the mouth it's very
specific he then said this i think you
can't do a venom story without knowing
spider-man's in the mix
somewhere
he then went on to say that there are
some events that need to happen before
spider-man and venom meet but spider-man
is always on their minds and in another
interview with jake's takes andy circus
essentially said the same thing
eventually spider-man and venom will
meet some things just have to happen
before then you know what i've been
loving about this promotion normally i
would be like man i wish people kind of
just focus on the movie you're
introducing carnage this is something
where the attention should be placed
there not so much about what comes after
this movie but what i find fascinating
is that tom hardy and andy circus both
seem enthusiastic with discussing the
spider-man possibility happening after
what tom hardy was saying at the fan
event of please don't spoil the
post-credits scene that happens here it
seems like they want this discussion to
be out there front and center with
building up the hype for venom let there
be carnage because that only puts more
butts in the seats for venom let there
be carnage for people they'll be like i
have to check this out this sounds like
a central view and it sounds like
they're actually going to get spider-man
involved in the mix even though there
hasn't been an official announcement
about it this is that rare case where it
seems like them discussing the future of
them crossing over with spider-man it's
something that they're they're not like
annoyed with having to answer because it
seems like that's probably what this
movie most likely is going to be
building yeah it seems like they're
happy to talk about it and it's funny to
me because andy circus's answer is one
of the better ones in terms of
deflecting like if they actually did it
and so i feel like maybe in a subtle way
they are kind of luring us and deliver
some kind of big surprise in venom too
that is the impression i'm getting right
now now most of you have probably heard
about the venom let there be carnage
post credit scene at this point and even
though it is just a rumor it does appear
to be pretty legitimate there's leaked
audio of it out there right now that
there's leaked audio but you never know
a fan showing to some lucky fans out
there and some of them after they saw
the movie went to the internet and
posted what they saw some fans are never
getting invited again
a rumor because they could simply be
trolling we've seen this happen already
with spiderman no way home people create
fake things fake photos fake trailers
all of the time and pass them off as
leaked however this does seem to be a
little bit more legitimate and
considering the fact that sony is now
saying venom's universe is expanding it
would make sense that we would see
spider-man in the post-credits of venom
carnage based off of what we've heard
about the rumor for the post-credits
scene and spoilers coming up if you
don't want to hear any about the rumor
it looks like it's going to be tom
holland spider-man according to the
rumors if they do come true it's going
to be very clear that it is in fact tom
hall and spider-man they're obviously
not going to say hey yeah and venom 3
spider-man and venom are going to meet
however we have a recent report from
daniel richmond stating that that is the
case according to a report from his
patreon spider-man will be in venom
three according to
it's happening and considering the fact
that the multiverse looks like it's
actually going to affect the venomverse
in some way shape or form whether that's
the two universes colliding or maybe
they've been in the same universe the
whole entire time who knows but it looks
like they are going to be going up
against each other okay to me two things
come to mind one is i think they might
be a little happy that the post-credits
scene leaked because that will mean more
people will probably want to go just to
watch that two i find it very
fascinating that spider-man is gonna be
in venom three and not the other way
around is it gonna be venom three that
features spider-man how would venom be
the villain in that movie just
spider-man be the villain in that movie
because you're only in eddie brock's
perspective would you have it like be
you know like hate whoever you're gonna
be watching both their perspectives you
know that would be cool
or it's going to be godzilla versus kong
where they team up at the end against a
big machine yeah maybe yes more likely
there is one where they had to fight
carnage i find that very interesting i
find that very very interesting and
considering the post-credits scene rumor
considering the marketing that sony is
doing right now and considering what tom
hardy and andy serkis have recently said
i'm gonna say that it's gonna happen of
course it's rumor right now but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof thanks for
always reporting spider warren yeah guys
subscribe to cosmo if you haven't done
so already you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell hit
that like button we're not stopping not
until december and even then there's
probably gonna be more to talk about
because you know that marvel movies are
always like now look at the future look
ahead thanks guys for being here and
being on board the spider-man train with
us